instance methods class methods and
static methods what are they how do they
work and when should i use them
this video was supported by hostinger
who's having a black friday sale choose
your favorite web hosting plan
hostinger's premium shared hosting plan
is only 199 a month and that comes with
a free domain by the way click the link
in the description and use coupon code m
coding in all caps at checkout to get up
to 91 off all yearly plans it's really
easy to register your first free domain
and if you have multiple websites that
you want to manage it's easy to add them
and keep track of them all in one place
if you've ever thought about making your
own website please consider using
hostinger
instance methods or just normal methods
if you prefer are supposed to operate on
a specific instance of a class
when you call an instance method on an
instance of a class that instance in
this case a gets passed as the first
parameter to the method
this of course allows you to read from
or modify that specific instance of the
class but sometimes when you write a
method you don't really care about the
specific instance of a class or maybe
you don't have a specific instance yet
that's a good signal that what you're
doing might be a good candidate for a
class method or a static method
here's a basic calendar class that just
stores its events in a list the add
event method should just be a normal
instance method because different
calendars can have different events for
scheduling purposes it might be a good
idea for my calendar to be able to tell
if a certain date is a weekend or not
whether something is a weekend doesn't
really depend on any particular calendar
although it is related to calendars
all calendars better agree on whether or
not a certain date is a weekend
assuming of course we're ignoring people
that live close to black holes we
acknowledge that this function doesn't
care about any particular calendar
instance by deleting the self parameter
and marking it as a static method
now we can call is weekend on a date
even without referring to a specific
instance of a calendar if we just happen
to already be using an instance of a
calendar we can still use it this way
though
next suppose i want to be able to read a
calendar and construct one from a file
you definitely don't need an existing
instance of a calendar in order to read
one from a file you just construct a
calendar do some stuff read from the
file and then return the new calendar
that you constructed
so you might think this should be a
static method and you could implement it
that way but it's actually a better fit
for a class method
notice here how we're referring to the
class itself inside this method
the main problem with this is that it
breaks inheritance here i have a work
calendar that's inheriting from calendar
if i then try to call the from json
method from my work calendar i would
expect to get a work calendar out but
the from json method had hard-coded a
plain calendar so it's going to return a
plain calendar instead probably not what
you wanted
what i most likely want is to be able to
refer to whatever class it is that
happened to call this function so that i
can create an instance of that class
well that's exactly what class method
does
class method inserts as the first
parameter of the function the class that
the method was called from so if i use
work calendar from json then class will
be work calendar but if i just use a
plain calendar from json then it'll be a
plain calendar
this is very similar to how a normal
method works except instead of inserting
the instance it inserts the class
just like a static method though you can
call a class method from an instance of
the class
written this way i think it can be a
little bit confusing why you're calling
something like this on an instance of
the class when that instance is just
ignored though
however this can be useful if you want
to call a class method or a static
method from a regular one
it basically just saves you the
inconvenience of having to call type on
self
so that's the basic difference
functionally an instance method gets an
implicit self parameter as its first
argument a static method doesn't get any
implicit first argument and the class
method gets an implicit first argument
of the class by the way the names self
and class are just convention
you can call them whatever you want that
won't affect what actually gets passed
to the function
an instance method will be past the
instance even if you name it class
so don't do this just stick to
convention and call itself
the only exception to that is for meta
classes but meta classes are weird in so
many ways so don't worry about it
so what are the typical usages of static
methods and class methods
static methods are actually pretty
uncommon static methods generally don't
use anything in the class or any
instance of the class so why are they in
the class at all
why put is weekend inside of the
calendar class instead of just making it
a freestanding function
a lot of people would argue that it
should just be a freestanding function
get rid of static method altogether and
just put it up here outside the class
in most cases this is exactly what i
would do i wouldn't use a static method
i would just have a freestanding
function
in a lot of cases this would make even
more sense than having it inside the
class because there could be other
classes that might want to use this
function
something like a time zone class or a
date time class might also want to know
if something is a weekend
why should this function be in the
calendar class as opposed to one of
those other two
but if the function really truly is
somehow tied to the class itself then
you might want to use a static method
for instance here's a matrix class with
a can multiply method
it takes in two matrices and tells you
whether or not their shapes are
compatible in order to multiply them
you certainly could move it outside the
class but in that case can multiply is
just too general
it loses too much context if you move it
outside the class
if it was outside the class i would
probably try to add something like
matrices onto the end of it so that i
know that it's associated with that
class
the fact that i'm doing that though
tells me that it's probably intrinsic
enough to the class that it should just
be part of the class but even still this
matrix class is probably in a file
called matrix.pi
so maybe just that context is enough and
it doesn't need to be a static method
so you can see this is why static
methods are pretty uncommonly used
they're basically never needed and when
you do use them the justification for
doing so is shaky at best
class methods on the other hand are
extremely common to use and searching
for them in the standard library we see
that they're almost exclusively used for
alternative constructors
this from json function actually was an
example of an alternative constructor
they're usually called from make or
create something
and their purpose is to just make an
instance using a different set of
arguments
finally how does static method and class
method actually work
they're actually super simple to
implement in python because of the
descriptor protocol
here's basically the entire
implementation
when you create a static method it wraps
some function then when you go to
retrieve the static method in order to
call it it just ignores the instance and
the class that it was called from and it
just returns the wrapped function
technically in python 3.10 they made
static methods callable so you can call
them even from outside a class in this
case it just forwards the arguments to
the wrapped function
and then here's the implementation of a
class method
again it just wraps a function
and then when you go to get the class
method it binds the function to the
owner which is the class
a normal function would bind to the
instance so we just change that to the
class instead
and the reason that i'm able to do this
is because normal functions implement
the descriptor protocol
calling get on a normal function is how
you bind function to a specific instance
so in this case we just use that
built-in ability to bind to the class
object instead of the normal instance
object
and technically the second argument is
just ignored but i do like to just put
it in there anyway
that's all i've got thanks to my patrons
and donors for supporting me don't
forget to like comment and subscribe see
you next time